none of us are perfect and also i have
done things well in hindsight that would
think
could have done this differently the key
is you need self-reflection you need to
understand what you're doing so what you
got to do
is make sure there's always people
around you as a leader that have the
ability to say no to you and
that these are the people that you're
listening to
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders and this
episode is all about soul meet ralph
specht ceo of spark 44
ralph is a visionary business leader and
creator of the soul system a framework
that aligns value creating employee
action with broader corporate strategy
through shared understanding and shared
purpose
as a founding partner of spark 44 he was
the architect of an innovative industry
first joint venture with jaguar land
rover which grew under his leadership as
ceo to a global revenue of more than 100
million dollars and 1200 employees
previously he consulted with global
brands for 22 years with mccann ericsson
during his 25 years in executive roles
one key question kept him awake at night
how do we build and sustain a
human-centric performance culture his
driving vision is to make soulless
companies a thing of the past
ralph specht welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you very very much for
joining me today how are you i'm doing
great mathias great to be on the show
thank you very much for joining me let's
talk about you know companies building
great companies uh companies with
purpose and and and you know a kpi
that you've developed and that you've
been thinking about that that looks to
be a more much more important kpi than
that the nasdaq set out and the s p 500
and the dow jones the soul index and the
soul framework as you call it so ralph
thank you very much for joining me today
it's my pleasure to be with you today
tell me a little bit about yourself
before we dive into
the soul framework and the importance of
soul within companies
who are you ralph in in this whole
trajectory of company building an
executive within companies
so
the last thing i did in terms of my
corporate world life it has been
being a co-founder of a startup back in
and i left the
the company that we built
in 2019
uh at that time i was the ceo of the
company company was called spark 44 it's
been a joint venture with jaguar and
land grover an industry first global
marketing
joint venture
and prior to that i've been working with
mccain erickson in the advertising and
marketing space for over 22 years
so
you could say
a global business leader in the
marketing space is kind of one of what
i've been doing and
as i stepped down from my
post at spark 44 i received numerous
messages from colleagues from all over
the world because we had like 1200
people and 19 offices across
across the world
and those messages went far beyond to
what you would expect a
normal if there's ever going to be a
normal farewell message that you receive
from employees and what was so different
was that all of these messages honed in
on the culture that we had built and so
as i was contemplating about all these
messages on my iphone i was like okay
i mean i could do two things right leave
it on my iphone and look at them every
now and again when i'm getting
sentimental about it or
actually take the lessons learned from
those
executive years that led to people
writing these messages and and create
something that helps leaders to build a
corporate culture
that
actually
is
true to the business and and really
successful for
them so i want to ask you even before we
we get to that i mean obviously it's
beautiful
the people
enjoy the workplace and they feel
fulfilled and with the purpose and
involved
but why is it important from a business
perspective what what validation do we
have
that this thing we call company culture
soul purposefulness why is it even that
big a deal in our world
it's a huge deal
and
i think people are
on a journey to realize that is bigger
than they thought
there's a wonderful study from
a company called oc tanner in the us
and they issue a global culture report
once a year
and what i call a business with soul or
a company with soul is what they call a
thriving culture
and when they
analyzed thriving cultures
they had some remarkable results and
then those results are
are stunning actually so
not only our employees
or
our companies that have a thriving
culture
13 1 3 times more likely to have highly
engaged employees
or they have an eight times higher
incidence of great work or they have a
double likelihood to have increased
revenues they also have
create a situation
an environment
actually
where employees are three times less
uh
in danger of burnout situations and the
companies are
three times less likely to face layoffs
so
double revenue three times less likely
layoffs happier
uh employees less burden situations
what else do you want
what else do you want now and and tell
me a little bit about this soul index
global top 20 that what what how is what
is this and how does it fair with the
the other in other similar indexes
whether it's the nasdaq dow jones etc
so
when i when i finished writing the book
building corporates so
obviously what you do when writing a
book is you study lots of research and
surveys and and you dive into it lots of
interviews
and
um
as i was finishing it and had
embraced all these studies i thought
actually
there's something interesting here
because
it seemed to me
that
companies that score high on employee
engagement scores for instance or
employee satisfaction scores
actually have a better business similar
to what the oc tenor research suggests
so what i did was basically take
a number of studies that focus on
employee engagement employee
satisfaction and ceo approval from
employees plus some
business success
studies best little brands from internet
for instance
and created
a new ranking and that ranking is what i
call the sole index
and
as i was
finishing the work
and had
the
top 20 companies
on my excel sheet i i handed that over
to uh to some financial analysts and
they looked at that and they came back
with something that won't be big time so
from 2016 to 2020 that index delivered
uh
return
nasdaq did 180 and i think uh dow jones
was 75 and and s p 583 so
if you if you really
dive into the data what you see is
companies that put an emphasis on
workplace culture
do better
in
do are better off in business and
and have uh
are enjoying much greater performance
and then and obviously in the second
world we'll get into you know ways to
ways to measure them and ways to
understand this
but you know it
was it you know you're you're hearing
these messages you're receiving them
after leaving the corporate world is
this something you know company building
the culture the soul of a company is
this something that that you took with
you throughout your career is this
something that sort of naturally
happened
due to your leadership style that then
gave you an aha moment when you left
when i when i started the corporate
world i started back in i think was 1984
so quite quite a while ago right and i
started with it with a german publishing
company battlefront which was the
largest public
publishing house
across the world at that time
and their founder uh had set up a
what he called a constitution for the
company which basically similar like a
the constitution from a state
uh putting up all the values and the
behaviors that that he wanted to see in
the company that was the first time i
got in touch with
corporate culture
in reality
and
i was a young man at the time and
i read it and i and i witnessed how it
was taken into interaction inside the
company with the various colleagues and
departments
that i had
as i moved on and
moved to nepal to mckenna erickson
ericsson
obviously you
uh you cannot not experience a corporate
culture right every company has its
culture but only few have got their soul
and
leadership plays a vital part in in in
setting the north star
um and and and making sure
the behaviors that
work with the intended culture
are supported or not and and i've seen
both so
uh and as we found in spark 44 the five
of us
and i remember still to that day we were
five founders
and uh we were sitting in london in an
office of a befriended agency and and
thinking about how do we
build the thing now well how do we
design the organization how do we
make sure that the culture can emerge
that we can be proud of and
um the way we did it was we we looked at
what we did not like
what we had and i had seen before
and and all of us were in our mid 40s
early 50s so we had already seen a lot
and uh
putting all of that on the flip chart
organizing it by a few principles and
then
defining and designing the organization
as we wanted it to be
was the major step to to get there so
you can you can say it's always been a
part of my life but
um
[Music]
there's
it's a rare opportunity that you can
design an organization from scratch
right usually
you get somewhere and there's something
already there and you gotta
work with that i mean one of the
greatest examples of the company culture
turnaround is microsoft with what madela
did and and
how he focused on
culture that
back in the day i think 2014
um and the linkedin integration is a
great example of that and now we're
going to see how that
pans out with the activision
integration which is probably going to
be
uh something to watch closely as you
could have a larger clash of cultures
than these two
incredible so so you know ralph tell me
a little bit about building corporate
soul you know fast forward to today uh
you've authored this book and now you're
you're you've spent a lot of meaningful
time thinking critically about you know
not just what you did at spark 44 which
sounded like a great success especially
you know with the biggest validation of
of the messages you've received when
leaving
but now thinking you know more generally
about what can companies do to to to
have better clarity on their soul
empower their employees and and
hopefully make it to your
soul index global top 20.
first of all what does it mean to have
good soul within a company what did you
learn how do you distill that into some
parameters that you can measure
so
i created this framework which i call
the sole system and when you look at
that it's got three layers three levels
if you like at the center is purpose
the next level is
context at the third level is what you
experience in the workplace and in my
words this sounds like
starts with a shared purpose
that you need the shared understanding
then you need the shared behaviors so
the word shared happens every time i
talk about this and shared is really
critical because
you can
have the greatest ideas
on earth
if you
cannot find a way to share them in an
appropriate and meaningful way with
anybody any stakeholder that you got
you're not going to get anywhere so
on purpose and we've had a purpose
discussion for the last 10 years um and
everybody now knows that you need
purpose and so that's not the question
the question is what do you do with it
and what i'm saying is number one you've
got to make sure that your purpose is
shared by your executive team and shared
with all stakeholders if you don't have
that it's a useless exercise
then you get to the shared understanding
and that means
we need to talk about vision we need to
talk about mission and we need to talk
about values and we need to talk about
spirit spirit is something that's often
forgotten
and spiritually is the intended
corporate culture if the management team
sits together and says okay this is kind
of we're clear on purpose we clear our
vision on our vision and our values
what spirit do we want this place to
have
how do we want it to feel like
and once you've got all that
you get to the third level which are the
shared behaviors and they basically look
at everything
that's happening inside a company how do
you
hire people how do you promote people
even how you fire people
um how do you
uh find partners
partner companies to work with how do
you deal with customers
all elements of the ecosystem
that make the corporate culture
tangible and
to me if these three
levels the shared purpose for shared
understanding and the shared behaviors
are in sync if there is an integrity
between those three
companies have a great opportunity to
build corporate soul as i said every
company has got its culture only few
would come and so
does this necessarily mean that
everybody has to be to be in agreement
on the shared purpose and the shared
activities and you know is there any
doesn't need to be an agreement on on
the type of behavior that we need to
have in the company and the type of work
that we ought to be doing to solve
whatever we're aiming to solve
absolutely i think
the alignment at the leadership level is
absolutely critical if that doesn't
exist you're not going to get anywhere
and
but there's been another discussion over
the past few years about individual
purpose
and that's kind of what it was your
purpose was my purpose and what's
everybody else's purpose and that's a
fine discussion there's nothing wrong
with that discussion
but i ask everybody to
pay a bit of attention because
the corporate purpose and the individual
purpose of individual people within the
workforce
are not necessarily the same every now
and then you find situations where they
overlapping where they are with whether
it is
[Music]
whether synonymous more or less but that
is a rare exception and i don't think
that is required but what is required is
the leadership team is clear about its
purpose
that the extended leadership teams are
clear about their purpose or the purpose
of the company and that they talk and
communicate well with their workforce
and all other stakeholders that
everybody understands what the firm is
about
where it wants to go and how it wants to
do it and in terms of the behaviors
whatever really helps is if you
kind of code
certain experiences so that people
always understand this is happening
because
we got this or that or the other and
things happen
in a way that people can connect them
with
the purpose and the division of the
mission
so before we understand you know
what actions we need to take right now
we need to understand what's the current
status of our company right if i'm
sitting here and i have a company and
i'm trying to distill and to understand
where am i at where do i need to you
know be putting my my time and effort
are there tangible ways for me to to
understand that sort of to give myself a
score on the soul of my business or the
soul of my company
well
well first of all
i've had a number of conversations with
with with leaders who came to me and
said well
our company is great with great
corporate culture i think we got
corporate song and
my response to them has always been
great congratulations
it's great to hear that you're caring
about it
the only thing where i would be a bit a
little bit careful is i'm always
contemplating whether it's the leader
who can talk about to us whether the
company has got sold or not to me it's
the employees who can tell you when the
place has got so and you can see it
there are
the the likes of glassdoor
where
people just post their views and a lot
of people have said to me you know but
it's usually biased
and say yeah it is biased
there's nothing wrong with it with the
bias there but the bias is true for
every every company so
between companies you can compare it
and so you can see
um for instance if you compare adobe and
and
which is a company that is not so much
in the spotlight all the time
uh with apple that was
in the spotlight every second day
and you look at the
glassdoor scores or comparably you've
got the
various
kpis about how the companies are doing
quality of engagement and satisfaction
and
split down into lots of areas like how
they're doing on diversity and so on and
so forth
and you can see the differences and then
you're not surprised that adobe is the
number one company in the solar index
right
that makes sense now
ralph take me back through you know if
you're thinking back
to the research you've done and the
different understandings that you've
gained what is something non-trivial
that you've learned
about
soul and about company building
that you know when you left spark 44
maybe you know maybe you knew maybe you
didn't but but it it's not
for for entrepreneurs around the world
what did you learn through this research
i think most most leaders
intrinsically
want to create good companies
i haven't really came across come across
anyone who
didn't want that in the first place
but every now and then leaders get off
track
and
and it's easy to get off track to lose
uh
to lose the
straight straight line here
and
it's easy because
there are so many pressures there's so
many constraints
and there are so many things that are
happening along the way that um
every now and then
people say
ah well i gotta focus on corporate
culture next time but right now we're
gonna hit that deadline or we're gonna
make that
milestone or whatever it is
what they
do not
understand or do not realize
at that moment is
they might be treating a short-term
something
uh for a long-term loss and and
i mean
there's hardly anybody who that's
perfect right none of us are perfect and
also i have done things where
in hindsight that would think
could have done this differently the key
is you need self-reflection you need to
understand what you're doing so what
you're going to do
is make sure there's always people
around you as a leader
that have the ability to say no to you
and
that these are the people that you're
listening to
um you need to create a
sense of
like internal ambassadors
that are not part of the leadership team
um so basically the next generation
of leaders who
ideally become the ambassadors for your
shared purpose
and make sure that
every now and then you're reminded of
where you're going and then
you better every now and then look at
the oc tenor
piece and
look at 13 times
more engagement and
double revenues and you should think
okay so what can i do to make that
happen and communication is a key
element
ralph thank you very very much for
joining me and for sharing your journey
and your insights
and your understanding with me uh
definitely things i'm going to be taking
with me for the long run is i
build my own companies and i think
through a type of leader that i want to
be the type of company that i want to
build
a very optimistic note on your deep
understanding that the end entrepreneurs
want to build great companies
but you know we're human and we need the
skills to do that and we need to
understand that the way we perceive
something is not necessarily the way
that the rest of the organization
perceives it so knowing how to ask the
right questions
and then being honest and answering them
and action oriented when thinking
through them
that leaves me with a lot of inspiration
so thank you very much ralph and stay
safe and stay healthy it's been my
pleasure thank you very
much thank you
[Music]